after the Civil War many of the Plains
Indians were moved to Oklahoma there's a
place in the middle of North America
with a story that you should know about
the one about the violent dust
people out
or the novel about a homicide and a
drought
or the songs and dances about rivalries
between farmers and cowboys it's the
story of what happened before all of
this the story of checkered board maps
and lines and private property and
broken promises all because of this this
place was a Dumping Ground for the
people that the U.S government wanted to
get rid of which is why today it has the
second highest number of first Americans
of any state it was once a random
rectangle that the US government used to
ship native populations after they
removed them with a new weapon of state
power
paperwork treaties and payments and
spreadsheets pretend Justice that's the
story we talked about in part one the
next part is how these first Americans
created a state of their own fighting
against their captors to retain one last
shred of sovereignty over their land the
land that had been taken from them over
and over again
frontier people had remade a continent
the United States of America
[Music]
hey before we go on let me tell you
something disturbing kind of which is I
recently learned that my name and all of
my personal details were on a people
search list it's just one of many sides
of this massive shadowy Market of data
brokers who collect loads of information
about all of us and then sell it to
companies so that they can Market to us
the reason I'm telling you all of this
is because it has to do with the sponsor
of today's video in cogni I'm very happy
that incognia exists you sign up and you
give them permission to go out on your
behalf to take you off of these lists we
have privacy rights that entitle us to
not be on these lists but it's really
complicated and bureaucratic to actually
do it and there are dozens and dozens of
these lists so instead Incognito does it
for you I've been signed up for
incognate for a few months now and it is
so satisfying you have this dashboard
that shows you all of the lists that
they found you on and then they show you
the status of each one the efforts that
they're taking to get you off this list
and then the best part is they show you
the list that you have been successfully
taken off of if you want to try this out
there's a link in my description it is
incognito.com Johnny Harris when you
click that link it helps support this
channel but it also gets you in on a
full refund within 30 days if you decide
that this service isn't for you thank
you incogni for helping me out here and
also for sponsoring today's video Let's
dive back into the story okay so
remember in part one I showed you how
the US government used bureaucracy and a
purchase particularly horrible law to
push out over a hundred thousand people
to push them off their land many of them
ending up here in a little rectangle
that the U.S called Indian Territory and
crucially in the process of kicking
these nations off their land the U.S
government promised that they would
leave them alone that they could live in
build their lives relearn their land
so over the course of the 1800s more and
more tribes are exiled and arrive here
to Indian Territory the territory gets
divided again and again as these tribes
are crammed into this one rectangle
which results in this map
and a reminder that each of these
nations had their own government and
culture and language and yet they were
all dumped in this one place and labeled
Indian
so they ended up here knowing that it
would be hard but okay at least we can
rebuild a new life without the anxiety
of white settlers unfairly claiming our
land oops nope here they come
The Westward Movement was like a great
tidal wave sweeping Westward past the
Mississippi River over in the East the
Americans had now convinced themselves
that it was their literal Destiny to
keep spreading West and as they're doing
so they stumble upon this rectangle this
rectangle that they thought they would
never reach but no they're not allowed
to settle here because it's allocated
for Indians by treaties like real
iron-clad treaties
okay but wait here in the center of this
map you see this little section what
does that say here let's look at a
different map
Oh unassigned Land
let's settle here when the land was
thrown open to white feathers and by
settle I mean not like buy the land or
sign anything just show up to this empty
looking flat area and just settle
soon these Imperial squatters are
farming the land they're building a life
a society in the west but right in the
heart of the territory that the US
government had signed treaties promising
to first Americans oh and by the way I'm
just gonna get this out of the way now
Maps around this time start to show this
weird little Panhandle that doesn't make
any sense literally called No Man's Land
because nobody really claimed it and
then a bunch of criminals started living
here because there was no law
anyway someday I'll go into that one
we're talking about Indian Territory and
word soon gets out that this place is
the new trendy part of town the federal
government is kind of hesitant like wait
a minute we had promised these people
this land like let's just back off
but the squatters kept coming and
clamoring and soon there was a railroad
that was built that went right through
here bringing even more settlers
and finally the government was like fine
you can move in and settle in this one
little section of unassigned land in the
middle of Indian Territory but it's
going to be first come first serve and
so we'll make it
a race yes a race like literally there
was a race there was a starting line and
there was a gunshot and 50 000 settlers
hungry for new land in covered wagons
dashed forth to claim some of this 2
million acres of unassigned land in
hopes of getting cheap property and
starting a new life
the tidal wave of Europeans continues
they're hearing about these mystically
huge plots of land in the west the
American dream as unassigned land
started to fill up the settlers started
to look around at all of this land that
yeah technically had been promised to
the natives but they weren't really
using it to farm so like no harm if we
just sort of set up shop here right
so they kind of start doing this and the
government has to get involved so in
1890 they draw this line it cuts Indian
Territory in half leaving all of this as
well as the random No Man's Land
Panhandle to become a new territory
they would call it Oklahoma
[Music]
so Indian Territory now is just this
land for the Five Civilized Tribes
that's what the federal government
called them but all the tribes that had
lived here were now in the new territory
of Oklahoma and their land was suddenly
up for grabs and once again here come
the maps and the documents and all the
stuff that basically made this feel like
it was official and right A lot of these
maps have squares on them look at these
squares perfectly checkered squares all
of these squares these checkerboard Maps
show us how differently European
settlers and their government saw the
world than the natives the concepts of
communal land use and lack of personal
property that tribes abided by was
considered backwards and uncivilized
from the European view they're not using
the land productively so we need to
create a system of grids and plots and
Land Titles to get the most out of this
land this process of drawing a bunch of
squares on the land that had formally
been promised to natives was called
allotment and it meant taking tribal
territory like this and drawing a bunch
of straight lines to make it a massive
grid and then they would find out where
Native families were living and allow
them to stay there but everything else
was up for grabs given and the race was
on and here come more of those weird
races for more in fact each bringing in
floods of settlers into this land that
had been promised by treaty to somebody
else and look these Maps start to fill
up with names Alice Roy Julia delage has
this Square these are people coming from
Europe looking for the American dream
and finding Maps full of squares and
land to claim a lot
this real estate boom came with a
marketing boom as well
Indian land for sale get a home of your
own Easy payments
possession within 30 days
and look they're advertising that here
in 1911 that they have 350 000 Acres
available for sale
there is so much land up for grabs
it was the same thing as before we
talked about in the first video but just
happening again in a different place by
different people it was maps and
documents and bureaucracy cutting down
native sovereignty and culture Square by
square
with all of this carving up settlers
start outnumbering the indigenous people
the five tribes were still technically
safe from all of this allotment for a
time but they saw what was coming they
had learned time and time again that the
United States government for all of
their treaties and Promises never
actually kept the agreements that they
signed and they were right soon there
was a law passed that said that all
tribal governments and tribal courts
would be abolished by 1906. so his
last-ditch effort to fight back the five
tribes gathered and devised a plan to
salvage some shred of their sovereignty
foreign
[Music]
this was a time when U.S territories
were making proposals to be States and
new states were popping up left and
right two of these tribes wanted to band
together and make a state of their own
this was their time
they called the state Sequoia in honor
of the man who created the Cherokee
writing system and so the year before
all the tribal governments were to be
abolished by law the tribes held the
Sequoia Constitutional Convention where
hundreds of Spectators gathered to watch
the delegates create and write a
constitution complete with a Bill of
Rights trade regulations tax policy
County borders and by the end of it they
had produced this 35 000 Word document
separated into 18 articles 270 sections
that had everything they needed for a
proper state it was unanimously ratified
and in a public vote overwhelmingly
endorsed by the citizens in Indian
Territory and honestly if you read this
document it's kind of a story from the
population to the economy to education
and taxable wealth they deserve to be a
state but then they appeal to the
humanity of the government that had done
so much harm to their people their
culture and their home they appealed to
this quote natural right of people to
govern themselves quote by the fact that
we constitute a separate and distinct
Community from any on Earth with a
different history associations and
ideals and hopes these people have been
boxed out time and time again and now
they were appealing to the values of
these Europeans who had taken their land
using their language and their legal
tools to make the case for their
statehood
[Music]
okay so now with their well-formulated
constitution their solid proposal their
maps all of it in hand the tribal
leaders went to Washington
ready to lobby for a state and
Congress didn't even look at the
proposal
like they didn't even look at the like
they didn't even like look at it
wasn't like a debate it's like they just
were like no of course not not it's like
Dead on Arrival
first just because of plain old Politics
the Republican majority at the time
didn't want a state that would mean more
senators and congressmen for Democrats
something that Republican president
Teddy Roosevelt especially didn't like
it was also about resources Sequoia had
oil and farmland that Oklahoma territory
didn't have and we're going to let the
native people have like all these
resources but in addition to this many
white lawmakers didn't like the idea of
a state run by brown people so the
proposal died Sequoia never became a
state if there was going to be a state
there could only be one and indeed two
years later a new map was drawn all of
this land that was going to be Sequoia
was swallowed into a new state the 46th
Oklahoma
but of course they wouldn't throw away
all the work that these tribes had put
into sequoia's Constitution so they just
sort of took it for themselves the
Oklahoma Constitution is basically word
for word what was written in sequoia's
Constitution one historian called it
quote the ultimate cut and paste job so
this is what Oklahoma looks like and
they reserved one small chunk for the
native people to govern themselves up
here so just as a quick recap time lapse
of the whole thing remember that first
Americans the people who had lived here
for thousands of years went from roaming
freely around all of this to being
driven out and dumped into this
rectangle and then eventually cut in
half and then grid it up Square by
square and sold
to then being further reduced to this
today there are 39 recognized tribal
nations in Oklahoma
but just one of them has a reservation
now listen this is one little shred of
the history of the people who lived on
this land this same process happened all
over the country as Europeans moved to
every corner of the continent after
first Americans were boxed out and lied
to and relocated the United States
government eventually settled on this
this is a map from 2020 that shows every
federally recognized reservation there
are 326 of them but remember that this
number leaves out the tribes that we
talked about in this story
but then later that year 2020 something
big happened a Supreme Court ruling
found that the treaties that the U.S had
signed with the Muskogee Cherokee
Choctaw Seminole and Chickasaw Nations
promising that they would leave them
alone in Oklahoma those were legitimate
treaties and that those treaties had
been broken when the U.S government just
drew all of them into the state of
Oklahoma and thus all of this land that
was set aside for the five tribes during
the whole relocation was in fact still
tribal land so what does that mean well
what it means at first is that Google
Maps shows these borders these borders
that we've been looking at these borders
from the treaties in the late 1800s but
if nothing else it makes Crystal Clear
how much of a charade all of this
Justice was back in the day all of the
treaties all of the legal processes it
was all pretend it was a sterilized
version of the classical imperialism
that these Europeans had kind of fled
from and yet it was incredibly effective
I mean the very way that I have had to
tell this story is proof of how
effective it is how are government
policy successfully created the concept
of Native American of Indian hundreds if
not thousands of different peoples with
unique cultures languages and histories
and relationships to this land all
lumped into one category on a
spreadsheet drawn into boxes the perfect
place to continue to wit away at their
distinct identities to erase their story
one broken treaty at a time
[Music]
foreign
hey everyone
um
so this topic is way bigger than I could
ever do in this video and I've struggled
with it for a lot of years in fact when
I was at Vox it was going to do a whole
borders series on
reservations and first Americans and it
just felt too
complicated to dive into and I've been
struggling with that so this this in the
previous video are my attempts to Broach
this history try to understand it try to
be sensitive to it while also
um aware of how little we can do in a
short video like this so if you have
other stories that need to be told on
this please let me know
um because I I want to know and I want
to cover more
um I just want to tell you about a
couple things number one something I'm
really excited about is that we have a
giant map poster that I designed with
some help from my amazing team and it is
a poster of all of the map projections
not all of them dozens of them uh with a
little explainer on why all maps are
wrong which is something I've been
thinking about for years so go check it
out it is a way you can support our
Channel while also having a cool poster
about maps in your room another way you
can support around here is The Newsroom
The Newsroom is our patreon it just
sounds way cooler to call The Newsroom
and so we call it The Newsroom it is a
place where you can go and support us
while also getting a couple of cool
perks like an extra video every month
you get an extra video which is a behind
the scenes of how we do what we do here
we have a big team of people very
talented fun interesting funny people
that appear in the behind the scenes
Vlog that publishes to Newsroom members
you get access to royalty-free music
from our composer Tom Fox and you get
the warm fuzzy feeling in your belly
that you are supporting independent
journalism
um so go check that out it's in
patreon.com Johnny Harris also I started
a company a few years ago called bright
trip
um it's where we do smart travel
education brighttrip.com we have Luts
and presets that help color our videos
and photos
uh and I think that's all the things I
need to tell you about so thank you all
for being here and for your ongoing
support for everyone who comments and
it is a conversation that we are in all
of the time as we read your comments and
hear your support here generosity we
will see in the next one
[Music]